so here's I want you to do if you got
your your diagram there if you've got
enough space to draw on it
we're actually would put some numbers on
this okay because we're going to go out
there and like we don't have a satellite
which tells us all the information we're
out there on foot
right so how is it them actually
constructed make a little subheading
which it is traverse survey this is the
name of what we're actually going to go
outside and do Traverse survey it's also
called same thing different name and
offset survey we want to be able to get
out there on foot and make a diagram
like this and that's what all these from
the wheels are about so for example I'm
actually just going to copy this diagram
again because I need a little bit bigger
I want you to imagine okay here you are
standing on this corner of the field
okay so you need to know where a corner
is and you want to put your line of
sight up into the other corner so we
already have this line running okay so
that's fine
now what you do is you start to walk up
okay in other words you're going to
start to traverse the field that's what
it means go all the way across but as
you do that like I want these
measurements right so as you walk you'll
get to a certain point where you like
uh-huh I can see this corner over here
and it is at right angles to this path
that I'm tracing out so maybe you want
to say 10 meters and you saw oh look I
can see the corner now it's right on my
on my right-hand side okay so I'm gonna
get someone else to walk along again
we're trying to build and I'm gonna
measure it out
okay now this is difficult when you are
people who are surveyors right they've
got these big fancy fingers call if you
wanna make this Nancy you can search for
it they're called they're called Fiat
alights so they basically look like
regular glorified tripods and this is
the itsy theme you might even you might
be driving along and you'll see some
guys like peering into it and there are
two opposite ends try to work out where
are we and getting the examples exactly
right so it's a bit difficult to do my
eye honestly but we'll be able to get
close enough and if you remember back on
that first lesson we talked about error
in measurement right and we know there
will be some errors what was one of the
ways of overcoming error in measuring of
do recall three different yeah do it
what's a lot of times or maybe get lots
of different people to measure the same
thing and then hopefully if we take the
average be pretty much so we'll do our
best so just on this I mean I'm just
going to do that again by eye let's
suppose you walk off in that direction
and you measure out 20 meters from where
you started out to the corner okay then
you these from the starting point you're
going to keep on traversing and then at
some point you look to your left and
like look here's the other corner so
again you take a measurement over there
I'm just guessing here suppose that's 50
you also need to know how far you walked
all the way across because remember you
need to know the length of this entire
diagonal I'm just gonna put another nice
round number on that and it's and then
off you go you're going to finish
walking and I'll get a final measurement
yeah okay now once you've got all of
those measurements the important thing
is we're gonna get out there and do the
measurements we'll come back here and we
work out okay how are we gonna crunch
these numbers to get prove it up and get
area okay sir we're gonna get out there
I'm gonna put you probably in groups of
three is it done good today
because that would be eight groups
yeah we'll find out in a minute okay so
I'm going to numb you off from 1 to 8
I yeah I contemplate never I want to get
out that much quicker as well so what
number you want to eight within your
group you're gonna need to get a trundle
wheel I don't think we'll have to but
we'll have more than enough of one for
each room in your group you're gonna
need to have at least a couple of people
who bring something to ride on so that
we go out there and remember I told you
we can choose which corners to go from
so in our eight groups we should be able
to get a couple of different corners and
I'd like us to see what kinds of
different measurements again okay so get
ready I'm gonna number you and once you
see people who've got the same number of
course participate that's okay no notes
I know who it is
okay Group 7 the group a trauma I'll
give you a bit of a hand but to us you
can do this as okay okay so in your
groups would you please get up Olivia
which I've read the
bring those to the front and in your
group you're going to need someone at
least with it's unknown feel you know -
if there's enough by the end you'll need
some people with your stuff to record
now just one last thing before we go
okay
this diagram quite hard to do when
you're on Thank You just think that
that's perfect time quite hard to do
when you're out there you don't even
know any of these legs okay so we have a
very particular way of writing each of
these numbers which is suitably concise
but it captures all the detail there and
then we can draw our diagram afterwards
so underneath where you've done this I'm
just going to go on to this next one I'd
like you to draw for me two vertical
lines which have one two three four five
rossum okay so something like this on
your page you're gonna have like here
your lines on your page okay so we just
want a nice succinct way of capturing
all this information so we want to mimic
what happens is we walk across the field
and you're counting these trundle wheel
clicks and trying to get a measurement
okay so what you do is you start by
saying okay I begin on one spot piano
which I then zero that's my beginning
you have two lines we're gonna put some
nothing moving and remember I said oh
okay you walked ten meters you want 10
meters and then you thought I'd better
measure so you write a 10 up on this
nexus runner we're heading up here we're
going across the surveying field and you
said okay what measure to the right and
so then after that you kept on walking
now remember this person who's going all
the way up there real is clicking and
clicking and clicking and then counting
so when you get to this next spot right
which is 40 what do you do there
actually I'm way too many rows
what do you do at that point you measure
in the other direction right and you
measured 15 you see that so I'm
measuring each of these numbers I like
where do I do something important on my
walk across the field okay so where I
start that's important where I took a
measurement to this direction that's
important indicate it that way where I
took a measurement to that direction etc
and it looks like I actually finished
what's the final number if I'm counting
along C's do I've gone 40 plus 20 that's
60 sorry I meant to talk okay so you can
see here that's about as minimal as you
can get if you wanted you wanted to be
more accurate or if you had a funnier
shaped field there's no reason why you
couldn't take more measurements but
that's gonna be a little bit complicated
out there so I will show you that back
when we come to this classroom and you
can see we can make these things longer
add more numbers on okay so let me
review one more time we're gonna hit out
there in your group of 3 4 2 1 4 1 well
she ate yeah ok who's the other 8 I give
you hey Chris okay well maybe you want
to jump up with another girl make that
okay I know but you perfectly collect on
the outside you're gonna need some
people to measure all the way across and
I would HIGHLY advise me this is why
you're in a group highly advise against
that same person also doing the other
measurements because then they're going
to lose their spot don't know what
direction they're going in it gets a bit
confusing okay